uh here with reaction former trump
economic adviser stephen moore former
trump treasury official secretary monica
crowley monica first they said it was
transitory he said in december the worst
is over
um and you know here we are we get the
worst number ever with no sign of relief
uh in sight
you know sean 9.1
inflation but hey no more mean tweets
right i'd kill for a mean tweet right
now to have you know buck 50 gas and
groceries that i could afford uh look
president trump when he handed off this
economy sean to president biden in
january of 2021 he gave him the fastest
economic recovery from any crisis on
record in one and a half short years
president biden and unified democratic
control in washington have taken that
economic recovery and destroyed it and
they've done it deliberately and of
course the the people bearing the brunt
of this economic catastrophe the most
are the middle class the working class
and the poor those are core democratic
constituencies those are the folks that
the democrats say that they champion the
most and yet their policies are crushing
those americans as well as every
american with no end in sight this was a
deliberate economic strategy sean to try
to re-engineer the u.s economy that's
why they spent between the fed and
congress last year between fiscal and
monetary response the federal government
spent nearly seven
trillion dollars last year that we don't
have and we can't afford and then biden
is running around blaming everybody and
their mother for this incredible
inflationary environment when it's his
own fault and he is not doing anything
and will not do anything to alleviate it
steve moore let me put up on the screen
the cover of your new report that has
come out not ready for prime time
players majority of biden appointees
have zero business years of business
experience zero
it's put out by you and john decker for
the committee to unleash prosperity
and then i'll put up the executive
summary
62 percent of biden appointees who deal
with economic policy regulation commerce
energy finance have virtually no
experience only one in eight has
extensive business experience the
average business experience of biden
appointees is only 2.4 years but this is
my favorite medium years of business
experience is zero and the vast majority
of biden economic commerce team members
are professionals now compare that to
the trump administration that had a
whopping
average cabinet member had 13 years of
experience medium years of experience
was eight
quite a difference and quite a different
result when trump left the white house
it was 1.4 percent the cpi now it's 9.1
percent
yeah sean this this this is uh solves
the mystery right of how how
the biden people could screw up the
economy so rapidly i wouldn't have
believed by the way 14 or 15 months ago
that it was possible that we could go
from 1.4 to 9.1 inflation so rapidly and
and i think this does answer the
question you've got a lot of people in
this administration most of them sean
who have no idea about what what it
means to run a business how to meet a
payroll anything about logistics um and
so you get people like pewdiepie
who is the transportation secretary
except guess what sean he doesn't know
anything about transportation and then
you have an energy secretary in jennifer
groundhome guess what she doesn't know
anything about energy i mean i could go
on and on and on with these people and
and you do compare that with trump and
one of the reasons i think that people
voted for trump uh in 2016 is americans
wanting a businessman who knows how to
run something and we don't have anybody
not
certainly not joe biden certainly not
kamala harris but almost no one in the
cabinet uh has that kind of experience
and i'm going to make one other quick
point sean
it's because they don't like business
this wasn't by accident they don't like
business men and women because they're
again they're in an anti-business party
and so they frown upon people who have
business experience
you know look at this we have
as
monica as as steve points out we have a
an energy secretary with no experience
we have pete buda judge what does he
know about transportation
we have a health and human services
secretary with little business or health
care experience and it goes on and on
from there 42 of the top 68 policy
makers have virtually no business
experience at all so you know why would
we expect any result other than they
just
hold to their rigid ideology their
indoctrination their brainwashing into
climate alarmism i mean they don't have
any point of reference based on this
no nor do they want one i mean these
people are pure neo-marxist ideologues
shawn and steve so stop looking for a
logical reason for what they're why
they're doing what they're doing they've
got a reason this is the plan the plan
is to re-engineer the us economy into a
more collectivist kind of model you know
don't forget that joe biden was barack
obama's vice president barack obama
spent most of his life prior to entering
politics as a community organizer but he
did have one little brief window of time
when he was in the private sector and
you know how he described that time guys
he described it as quote being behind
enemy lines
so you are dealing with true believers
who really do want to remake american
life and society by re-engineering the
us economy so it's it's not a
coincidence here the other thing i will
say about his cabinet is not only are
they true believing neo-marxists
essentially but they're also box
checking right so you know you you've
got the gay transportation secretary of
people of color in other uh positions
but this is the kind of result you get
when you get left-wing ideologues who
are also box checking you get this kind
of historic catastrophe that we're
seeing across the board
so steve we can only conclude that if
they're going to stay
married to these
policies and expecting a different
result would be pretty stupid and i
don't see any propensity at all
whatsoever to maybe rethink the policies
that have doubled energy prices and
resulted in a 41-year high of inflation
and record high gas prices energy prices
so there will be no change under this
administration the opposite so as we
speak you've got chuck schumer who's the
leader of the senate negotiating with
the white house and with joe manchin who
had been a hero but now he's negotiating
with schumer to do a new version of the
build back better bill you know what
that is uh sean that's 600 billion
dollars of new taxes on small businesses
300 billion dollars of new green energy
subsidies all we're doing is spending
money on green energy it has new
regulations on our drug industry
and it'll it'll increase government
spending and government taxes by another
trillion dollars you know what that is
sean that's pouring kerosene on a forest
fire gee i'm sure that makes every
american household happy tonight anyway
steve moore thank you monica always
great to see you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else